with five previous predator movies and
dozens of comics 28 teams the predator
had a wealth of material to draw from
not surprisingly some of that
inspiration hit the big screen in the
form of Easter eggs these little details
may have been easy to miss but they
point to some pretty crazy shared
connections in the predator universe
buckle up because we're taking a look at
all the small details you missed in the
predator spoilers ahead stick around a
special spear the two alien versus
Predator films have always been a source
of contention among fans some insist
their Canon while others say they're
little more than big-budget fanfic in
2004's
alien vs. predator the story is that the
Predators were breeding the Xenomorphs
on earth to serve as the perfect game
animals near the end one of the
Predators fashions a spear out of a
xenomorph tail and gives it to the main
protagonist Alexa so that they can go
hunt aliens together when Casey Brackett
first enters the project stargazer lab
in the predator she walks past to
display cases one of them showcases
several predator helmets and shoulder
cannon while the other contains the
xenomorph tail spear from alien versus
Predator then here before once Casey is
inside the main part of the lab Trager
hands a tablet that sums up everything
they know about the alien hunters as
she's flipping through the pictures you
can catch a brief glimpse of scenes from
the first two predator films Trager
continues by saying that they've been
here before in 87 and 97 those dates
refer to the first two movies 1987 is
the year the first predator was released
and although predator 2 was released in
1990 its story is set in 1997 that's the
obvious connection but this reference
might go even deeper starting in 1989
there have also been a ton of predator
comic books and novelizations one of
those was predator kindred which began
hitting stores in 1997 released as a
four-part series kindred details of
predators arrival in a small quiet town
buddy Wilcox a war vet who slowly
messing up his family life gets caught
up in the fight while on the run from
the police that's basically Quinn
McKenna in the predator war
Evette with a failing marriage who has
to fight the predator in a small town
while he's on the run from the
government the comic even features
panels that look a lot like some of the
scenes we see in the film even though
the story ends up a little different
maybe it's all coincidence but if that's
Shane blacks idea of a nod to his
stories inspiration it's definitely a
subtle one family ties not content to
simply mention past predator films Shane
black also added at least one solid
connection to the Predators predecessors
in the early lab scenes we meet a
bespectacled scientist named Shaun Keyes
he bites it pretty early when they're
captive predator escapes and massacres
the lab guys but if there's one thing
we're sure of its that his dad probably
would have been proud of the way he went
out in predator 2 Gary Busey plays Peter
Keyes a CIA agent who wants to capture
the predator alive it doesn't work out
and he gets cut in half for his troubles
actor Jake Busey who plays Shaun Keyes
confirmed in an interview that his
character was indeed the son of Peter
Keyes he looks just like him which isn't
surprising at all since Jake Busey is
Gary Busey's real son tech upgrades for
all those callbacks to earlier films
though 28 teens the predator did make
one smart change to the spine gatherers
their tech sure you could say that
giving the aliens better weapons better
ships and better armor gives the story
and narrative boost things are supposed
to be bigger and better in the sequels
number one the body count is always
bigger number two the best scenes are
always much more elaborate more blood
more gore carnage candy but it also
makes sense within the framework of the
predator universe after all human
technology has gotten a lot better since
the 80s and in be a weird twist if the
Predators hadn't made any technological
advances of their own in the past 30
years not even accounting for the
upgraded predator 2018 predator has
plenty of little tweaks in his gear set
that audience members may have missed
with everything from his bio mask to his
shoulder mounted plasma caster updated
for the modern day you won't be able to
hide in the mud to get away from this
one Arnold what's in a name it's not
unusual for movies to place little nods
to the men and women working behind the
scenes but the predator manages to pull
off a big one then hides it right in
plain sight during the scenes
Rory school you can clearly see the name
of the institution both above the front
door and on the lit sign out front
Lawrence a Gordon middle school that's a
reference to producer Lawrence Gordon
who worked on the first two Predator
films as well as the 2018 one in fact
Gordon has been part of the production
team on iconic movies since the 70s
producing everything from Xanadu to die
hard to the upcoming Hellboy reboot he
was also involved with 1979's the
Warriors hence the school slogan home of
the Warriors now he's been immortalized
forever as a school that gets torn apart
by a bloodthirsty alien math lesson
during the showdown between Quinn and
Trager near the end of the film think'st
her into a brief standoff with both
sides hunkered down behind vehicles in
an attempt to defuse the situation
Trager shouts out for Quinn to surrender
saying he's outnumbered because it's six
versus seven immediately a bullet flies
catching one of triggers man in the head
and Quinn quips who taught you math like
a lot of the movie it's played for
laughs but it's also a subtle callback
to one of Shane Black's previous movies
Kiss Kiss Bang Bang in this detective
comedy Robert Downey jr. plays Harry
Lockhart a bumbling thief who gets drawn
into a murder mystery while taking
detective lessons from Val Kilmer's
character trying to get some information
from a bad guy
Harry puts a single bullet in a revolver
and pulls the trigger where is the girl
who just do shocked he tries to
calculate the odds of the bullet
actually shooting on the first try put a
live round in that gun yeah yes the best
jokes are the ones you repeat over and
over
[Music]